politique avec elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lundi politique gay le dantec en 2015
elle avait choisi de faire une pause
après avoir enchaîné pendant des années
les mandats au conseil régional conseil
départemental
le voilà qui revient pour briguer un
mandat de maire au port à faudrait qu'il
a déjà occupé dans les années 90 en 2013
il avait expliqué sa rupture avec le
parti communiste réunionnais fondé par
son père il a 60 ans et ce côté là pas
de retour en arrière même si la figure
paternelle et bien toujours présente
pourquoi tenter de revenir aujourd'hui
dans l'arène politique comment comptent
ils ils parvenir sans les moyens d'un
parti politique pour défendre quel
illégal projet pierre vergès ancien
maire du port ancien conseiller régional
et conseiller départemental l'invité de
la vie politique sur la première jusqu'à
13h vos questions à partir de 12h45 au
02 62 99 2000
bonjour à tous merci d'accepter notre
invitation
vous avez présenté votre candidature à
la mairie du port
vous avez profité ce week-end de la
toussaint pour faire cette déclaration
devant le cimetière paysager
il y avait plusieurs réseaux à choisir
ce lieu la symbolique mais après
politique oui ben je crois que
j'ai toujours souligné qu'il faut que
l'on continue à cultiver la symbolique
d'1 h ans que l'on mène que ce soit au
plan politique ou autre je pense que
c'est très important et donc pour nous
envisager de nous engager pour une
bataille électorale ne pouvait se faire
qu'à la faveur du rappel de la nécessité
de ne jamais oublier d'où l'on vient et
on peut se projeter dans l'avenir mais à
stricte condition de ne jamais oublier
notamment celles et ceux qui ont permis
de faire ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui
alors le 3 novembre
c'est effectivement les sept années qui
se sont écoulées depuis la disparition
de ma mère qui était en même temps une
militante en faveur la cause des femmes
n'est pas seulement et ça a été
l'occasion par une femme qui est dans
notre équipe qui va deuxième sur la
liste françoise tard elle de rendre
hommage non seulement à laurent qui se
sont engagés dans des périodes bien plus
difficile que celle d'aujourd'hui est
donc c'est symbolique
ensuite nous nous retrouvions sous un
gagnant puisque c'est le symbole de
notre logo du cas effectivement on est à
l'image de cette sève qui continue de
nourrir je pense que l'on a fait notre
annonce parce que le bail ans et ne
tient pas s'ils se déploie sans d'autres
racines qui permet de tenir sur les
habitants et c'est un peu le clin d'oeil
aussi à cette exigence j'ai posé une
équipe je ne veux surtout pas être celui
qui réfléchit qui désigne et qui agit
seul et on voit tout un symbole dans un
signe chez la ba oui mais c'est un signe
qui est sale comme vous le savez puisque
l'architecte avait conçu à la demande de
presse lorsqu'il était maire du port
c'est un arbre de vie et se font des
feuilles et pour montrer que la vie
continue mais que ça ne sera pas un lieu
qui doit être austère on va regard sur
eux sur cette question d'héritage
police mais ça va pas vous présenter la
censure sans l'étiquette roi sol sans
l'appui du parti communiste qu'est ce
que ça change
bajeux ça change que effectivement un
moment donné on avait une perspective
réunionnaise qui était partagé cette
perspective aujourd'hui je ne le perçois
plus et c'est la raison pointage avait
dit à votre collègue qui m'a interviewé
hier que même en cas de victoire en 2001
ce n'est pas du tout écrit qu'il y aura
un parti politique qui se construira un
énième parti pour faire quoi
et donc je voulais c'est vrai que ça
change des choses parce qu'il faut qu'on
travaille beaucoup plus en équipe
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'intendance si on
peut dire qui suit pour les problèmes de
dépenses campagne pour les problèmes de
l'enregistrement de sa sueur pour toute
la communication
mais ce n'est pas un problème tout ça ça
prend ça n'appartient pas aux musiques
mais en même temps vous disiez il ya
quelques minutes que vous vouliez une
équipe et pas juste vous mais le fait
que ce soit pas un parti c'est quand
même malgré tout c'est vous qui allez
porter cette ce mouvement cette
candidature c'est l'autre n'ont cessé
vous personne qui va être centrum c'est
vrai que je suis tête de liste c'est
évident mais à dr mois ou rejet des
personnes qui ce qui aurait pu être tout
autre cas pas mais qui ne prend pas le
nom qui n'apprenait pas aussi
d'expérience c'est évident mais je me je
m'attache je mets un point d'honneur à
ce que des responsabilités leur soit
confié de magna ce que je ne sois pas
celui qui soi-disant l'homme ans
qu'est-ce qui fait tout et qui prend
tous les instruments et on a une équipe
on a par exemple est donc notre
programme qui est sur la plateforme
youtube je pense à ma main vous avez
sous la main
donc on avance en toute transparence
mais si ça a été possible ce n'est pas
seulement grâce à moi tout le travail
d'exiger camp peary t il y est
l'accompagnement une population qui se
sent abandonnée sur le premier démarre
anissa si je prends de recherche
d'emploi ce n'est pas moi ce sont
d'autres alors ça c'est pour les idées
mais après c'est pour la mise en
pratique pour l'organiser grands pas je
suis pas seul à partir soir c'est vrai
que c'est sur le port mais soyons
modestes travaillons notre jardin
d'autres travaillent le
notre commune peut-être que demain nous
retrouvons pour d'autres batailles mais
ça sera dans la clarté et la
transparence
parmi les candidats concurrents au port
il ya cadors qui convainc liste pcr le
maire-adjoint waro du plr qui on le
rappelle aux plus jeunes auditeurs est
une scission en quelque sorte du bcr
donc le sentiment que la famille
communiste rieuse en finit pas se
diviser en chapelle en groupe entre au
port en tout cas en ce qui me concerne
je ne suis pas dans un parti et vous
emmener j'en viens mais donc
effectivement je pense qu'il ya une
désagrégation de ce courant parce qu' un
certain nombre de choses pour moi
n'existe plus et ce qui a expliqué je
les tire ma tribune libre en 2013
au départ la fraternité c'était quelque
chose de mise en ce moment pour paul
vergès notamment lorsque lui a fait en
sorte que ce parti est au plus haut
niveau
lorsque ça n'existe plus vous vous
appelez pc world
on veut pca disparaît avec notre père
moi je pense je pense sincèrement je
pense y avait eu un engouement une
motivation une force qui dépendent et
par rapport à un projet par rapport à
une méthode d'action partage respect des
différents militants quel que soit leur
fonction
ces raisons que nous avons une charte d
alors c'est vrai que c'est en un an
réactions sont petit à expériences
passées une charte des valeurs pourquoi
parce que vous savez que quand vous
devez nihilus à vous pouvez considérer
en tout cas beaucoup on sait tentation
de dire qu'on est tous égaux mais
certains sont plus égaux que d'autres
eh ben ça ça passe par chez nous en tout
cas c'est bien qu'on a fait d'abord une
charte de valeurs et ses champs de
valeur et sur youtube et sur notre page
pensant même sur facebook et tout ça
veut dire qu'il n'y a pas d'alliance
possibles aujourd'hui avec le ps et le
plr zh est parce que malgré tout
idéologiquement vous êtes à ses proches
ainsi l île
genre d'appareil il ya eu des rencontres
notamment rabat et l'air bien sûr mais
après une rencontre avec le p r g
productions pourquoi pas le faire parce
que je vais vous expliquer mais d'abord
en ce qui concerne le pcr avec le pcr la
discussion n'a pas pu avoir lieu puisque
il disait que sa tête de liste et mais
policiers ont dit nous on y est hors de
question qu'on dise oui de la tête de
liste est hors de question on a d'abord
à présenter un programme présenté le
vote
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme ça
tous les coups nous avons présenté notre
programme et le pca présenta le chien et
bon vent pour dessert deux acquisitions
pour le plr on a dans notre programme
une exigence préalable c'est que notre
programme ne peut pas s'appliquer si la
mairie les partisans du peuple demandé à
beaucoup de porc doit 6 ans pense lance
il entre à l'intérieur la mairie et qui
sont surveillés par des personnes qu'ils
accompagnent jusqu'à thalys qui joue
qu'il sollicite world pour moi je dis
demain ça ne sera pas le cas si nous
arriverons à la mairie la mairie et la
maison du peuple
elle doit être ouvert voilà pourquoi il
ya des choses qui ne font pas négociable
les histoires de tête de liste on a
comme l'impression que derrière ça ya
aussi une histoire d'ego en fait dès 10
ans
vous savez bien vous qui est être là
dedans depuis mon qu'elle faisait sauf
que et d'un char de valeurs communes ici
il est hors de question que le maire si
nous accédons à cette fonction décide
des embauches et des licenciements
moi j'ai fait le christ se disant qu'ils
ont décidé seul donc de licenciés en
plein de confiance des personnes qui est
dépôt temps à la direction de l'ordre et
non politique
c'était mon cabinet
alors je veux bien que mon ego soit
celui de partager dans cette décision
qui appartient selon la loi et le code
est crucial au maire sol et asseoir donc
ça peut vraiment des goûts à ego égouts
et demi et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je vous dis il ya des choses qui sont
difficilement négociables autres et pour
ce qui nous concerne c'est un programme
je voudrais aussi sur la plateforme
youtube il a déjà été sur la page
facebook
donc nous avons un programme quel est le
programme de du plr quel programme du
pca quel programme notre avis je connais
pas mais par contre je n'ai pas dit que
la porte est fermée parce que vous savez
que non a souligné aussi dans une
intervention solennelle
partagez pas que moi qui parle sur cette
vidéo il n'y aura pas de remise en cause
de notre liste au soir du premier tour
quel que soit l'âge ou taille si nous
sommes un peu con quoi au deuxième tour
pourquoi c'est pas parce qu'on dit on
n'a rien on dit on discute jusqu'à mars
et discutons du programme ma façon de
travailler et de la liste bien sur des
places sur la liste
et si on est d'abord ensemble si on
n'est pas d'accord comme on faisait
faire croire aux gens aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont deux jours nous nous aimons tous et
à son office surtout quand en plus il
est non seulement des foyers critique
mais des insultes ou des coups bas
le premier tour entre ceux qui savent
lire et enjoint d'opale alliance entre
les deux tours mais dès lors que ses
dc10 ya oui absolument
hal qui est ce qui va discuter sur la
base notre char de valeur il ya des
centrales mais il ya des contacts entre
certains policiers mais il n'y a pas
j'ai roulé pour l'instant de
concrétisation mais les contacts ne
feront pas rompu et on le dit ça aussi
attention là je ne dis pas cela ou
saisit également sur notre intervention
expliquant nos des cas c est pourquoi il
y aura pas entre les deux tours de
fusion on doit cette explication aux
gens on ne peut pas dire on verra
et donc cette explication existe des
publics bien là risque qu'est ce qui
vous pousse vous personnellement à voir
revenir dans cette un petit con c'est
compliqué vous
dit vous avez été écarté un vécu des
choses parfois douloureuses qu'est ce
qui vous motive aujourd'hui à retrouver
vous avez 60 ans pourquoi comme j'avais
dit à un de vos confrères qui a site
internet qui avait interviewé j'ai été
sollicité beaucoup par exemple été
menotté par la disparition donc du
slogan le bon sens même il pense qu'il y
a une approche partisane
quand vous avez par exemple si de la
mairie vous avez comme air en photo les
eaux les parents ce qui est légitime
andré conçu même son compte est comment
les l'histoire comment il a accédé au
pouvoir avec l'aide donc à l'époque la
fraude
il faut le dire c'était quand même un
maire qui tend comptes à des gens et en
films de haut niveau je ne dis pas que
je suis absent sa propre rôle mais enfin
il ya énormément de gens qui vous disent
les pros le verger ça fait quand même
pour le port il ya même pas sa photo oui
demain
moi je suis pas pro 6 à 2 contient mais
je dis aux deux kills est de 17
appareils paulhan je dis oui j'espère
pour moi mais c'est pas moi qui décide
arrêtons avec une approche partisane et
donc si vous voulez si j'étais aussi
appelée aïd dago c'est parce que je
prends sinon un problème qui se pose
aujourd'hui et on a une confusion c'est
qu'on veut tout le temps
mettre la faute sur l'état ou l'europe
où les autres on sera trois ans dans
quelques jours ils vont jouer vous le
disiez un rôle important dans la commune
du port
l'incidence 71 il a aussi fondé pcr il
ya 60 ans est ce qu'il ya une bataille
d'héritage
finalement entre le pcr d'un côté et la
famille de l'autre est ce que est ce que
vous dit bah voila moi j'ai un héritage
direct et fils pca peut dire nous aussi
moi je suis extrêmement serein sur ce
plan parce que lorsque j'avais été
appelé intervenus chez pas c'était sur
votre antenne télé le lord et la
disparition de paul vergès j'avais dit
que l'héritage politique de progress
appartient de multiples personnes qui
jouent un rôle produits si on veut que
cet héritage produit le plus
effectivement que chacun comme vous
l'avez dit mettre un peu des gouttes
côté mettre de l'eau dans son vin et
envisage une perspective donc d'unités
pour faire prévaloir et prospérer ses
idées donc fêté ses 17 passes et
l'héritage je sais pas laquelle
en tout état de cause je sais c'est
qu'il y a des valeurs qui ont porté bien
haut
saint-amand qui aujourd'hui ne sont plus
cette hauteur des exigences et c'est
pour ça que je pense que j'ai un rôle à
jouer parce que je revendique une part
de cet héritage notamment quand je dis
aujourd'hui les gens ont besoin d'être
accompagnés c'est incroyable comme il ya
des dégâts commis par la façon dont
c'étaient des fonctions jeudi jeunes en
errance là les perdrix sans le
nombreuses femmes qui en sont déjà donc
maman très doux il est donc ils sont
démunis et qu'on doit aider
bien sûr est ce que c'est le rôle de la
mairie
seul absolument pas mais on ne peut pas
dire que ce n'est pas un problème c'est
le problème de rs c'est le problème de
la pratique la santé au plan tactique on
ne peut plus quand les personnes en
difficulté vous faire des démarches
auprès la fois on veut pas dire ce n'est
pas notre problème
en tant qu'élu on doit être aux côtés
ces personnes et lorsque je m'aperçois
que l'on critique par exemple et awad
sur le problème de la circulation
dépassement quand
et votre confort les voies réservées
c'est le gouvernement qui doit prendre
sa part décret ou ce sont les
agglomérations ici responsable appris
qu'il prend progressif et donc soulevé
attention lorsqu'on va au bout de nos
efforts parce qu'on le voit
difficilement on peut dire à l'état
vous ne pouvez pas nous laisser dans
notre situation alors qu'il ya encore
des problèmes mais on peut pas demander
tout le temps et à l'euro
quant au temps de notre boulot est donc
en ce sens je suis juge était d'accord
pour intervenir dans dans l'arène
politique aux ir et devant rapporter un
peu ses réflexions et cet argument
le maire a peut-être mon pouvoir
aujourd'hui nous savons parce que il ya
moins d'employés distribué j'allais dire
mais on peut allier sont aussi pour
certains l'image d'un certain
clientélisme politique
est ce que est ce que finalement
aujourd'hui être être maire c'est très
différent de ce que ça a été peut-être
vous les tyrannies ce que je faisais
campagne 3 pour les élections régionales
pour paul vergès et sa liste on celui
qui allait 52000 0,79 chômeurs
aujourd'hui on air on a dépassé ce gie a
explosé dont jouer on est plus en plus
d'un situation où les choses qui
inscrira longue durée aujourd'hui c'est
d'en mesurer il ya une déstructuration
de la société en ce sens on le voit dans
les crises saveeasy jeannois alors c'est
parce qu'on travaille
mais le pouvoir d'achat donc c'est dans
ce sens qu'il ya des situations de cette
société et le travail de maire est
beaucoup plus difficile mais c'est au
moment où il y a des moyens de
communication formidable qui développe
notamment quand je dis amérique qu il ya
eu moins de contacts et de moins dès de
soutien auprès des gens les plus en
difficulté et c'est ça je pense devoir
remettre en cause un maire doit être au
plus près de sa population demain parce
qu'il ya des difficultés et des défis à
relever
on doit et des personnes et on peut le
faire
c'est une sorte de moyens c'est une
histoire de moyens mais c'est aussi une
histoire de volonté je prends l'exemple
du port tout le monde sait qu'il ya un
divorce entre des entreprises et la
population portoise en recherche
d'emploi ce divorce et sur 10 mg des
quads et des impressions ou que c'est
pas facile à des entreprises à recruter
quand
mais si nous nous intervenons aider les
jeunes
moi je comprends que c'est un peu
différent parce que vous mettez aussi
parce que moi j'ai un peu prendre
quinquas qui quinze jours après ne vient
plus ou autre dont jouer il faut
sécuriser
quand on parle de sécurité c'est pas de
mettre des personnes pour réprimer des
jeunes rhodes
c'est travailler avec ces jeunes qui
voudront nous on a rencontré par plus
tard jeudi dernier
au départ c'était très tendu ainsi une
aigreur
une rencontre extraordinaire et contre
le tibet il faudra bien choisir demain
il faudra faire des sacrifices mais pau
affirmé des priorités et plus de
périscolaire
vous savez que l'autre vous ai parlé des
contrats aidés ce qui est quand même
beaucoup d'emplois jeunes qui
intervenait au nom n'était under mais
pas là où je voulais on a accompagné les
jeunes en cet endroit
voilà regretté prête à doit elle était
donc dans cet endroit à encadrer 6 l'an
prochain pour travailler aux étudié
avant 80 de ces jeunes après l'école
aujourd'hui 0 les dégâts des jeunes en
errance
il ya un an le mouvement dit si je vous
l'avais évoqué participants de se
mouvoir dans lequel il s'est dit
beaucoup de choses sur l'économie sur le
pouvoir d'achat mais aussi sur la
politique
le système démocratique qu'est ce que
vous avez appris ou de ce mouvement est
ce que ça vous a appris de l'état de la
société rennaise je ne peux pas dire un
peu on s'attendait à même si à un moment
donné certains politiques dont progrès a
souligné que l'on n'est pas la bride
dans une implosion sociale etc avance à
six y aura des soubresauts et donc
s'offrir un peu mais en tout état de
cause cette situation conforte notre à
mon analyse c'est que les gens ont
besoin d'être associé à ce qui peut se
faire et ce qui ne peut pas se le dise
pourquoi ne pas chauffer ce site
j'invite langoat voir dans notre
programme on ne fera pas une politique
dans la mandature kan élu sans associer
des personnes qui sont impliquées dans
la vie de la cité
y'a pas des élus et canadiens d'un
conseil qui s'appelle le conseil gagnant
vous avez des petits peut vous apporter
mes consultants qui vous est dédié ou
non alors c'est nous qui décidons
c'est ça le drame commencer juste pour
mettre en place cette démocratie
participative c'est le mot très bonne
coursé l'énoncé quoi qu est-ce qui
travaillent dans ce positionnement
culturel sur le plan de l'aide aux
personnes notamment par exemple vous
avez moi ma mamie nomme la france aux
airelles qui est ce qu'on sait déjà
qu'il faut des conditions et après 150
personnes une semaine venant demander de
l'aide pour une démarche auprès de la
caf propres rangs qu'elle douchy ça veut
bien dire qu'il ya donc un problème donc
dès à ces personnes mais elle n est pas
tous pris un autre qui fait part des
ordinateurs qui le fait une autre
association près du grès citant zéro
subvention ni la mairie les éau ça c'est
pas possible ça si on arrive ça va pas
se passer comme ça pourquoi parce qu'il
faut un travail d' aide à la
collectivité et donc si vous voulez
c'est persona elle doit être associée
demain à la politique que l'on veut être
choqués d'accompagner les personnes et
non pas écoulé fait notre boulot mais
nous on a été lu ça vaudra pas ce qu'on
fait c'est pas possible demain dans le
mouvement des gens aussi beaucoup
entendu un besoin de renouvellement de
la classe politique
un rejet de ces gens qui cumulent les
mandats depuis des années les années un
rejet aussi de ceux qui sont passés par
la case justice
vous coché plusieurs de ces cases est ce
que vous dit pas où on va y retourner
parce que le monde que les gens
attendent mon petit que le patron il
doit changer
moi je fais attention à ce qu'on dit les
gens je me dis ah ce mois il oublia ça
veut dire que les gens de sani sont déjà
musique
je crois que maze à nice et monsieur
gilbert annette
alors les gens dont les gens de venise a
alors voulu dire si vous voulez moi je
sais que certains le pensent
je leur laisse le choix de penser ce
qu'ils veulent moi c'est la population
qui doit elle suffrages et celle qui
doit déterminer ce soit des gens mais
sur la base
en tout cas c'est vrai d'un projet et ce
projet comme jeudi
il est présenté par mois mais pas
seulement vous verrez il est présenté
par les policiers et ce sont ces
personnes qui demandent la confiance des
gens s'il y en a qui souhaite pas parce
que des personnes étaient condamnés ce
sont les mêmes qui n'auraient pas voté
vous prélasser n'auraient pas eu la
route des tamarins gréco n'est
judiciairement j pour moi c'est un faux
débat
le vrai débat quant à roger ederson
s'est passé les six mois si démocratique
n'a pas été consacrée mais je vais vous
faire un aveu
vous avez des gilet jaune au c'est en
tout cas son trek moi mais je les
considère pas comme la référence mais je
les considère comme à plus pas moins
comme les citoyens du gros qui doivent
être associés demain ben aux décisions
que nous prendrons revenu sur le terrain
de lutte contre les choses plan pétrels
action pour l'emploi avec sept cent
mille euros à la clé il est sûrement
millions
oui ce qu'ils veulent avec des emplois
et des impôts et des pecs douze mille
par an assurés avec des emplois francs
avec des emplois ces exonérations de
charge à temps là est ce que ce sont de
bons beats vous dit rien ce qu'il a fait
non peut pas dire ça c'est ariane et que
c'est loin loin loin de ce qui devrait
être fait c'est évident et ça me
rappelle c'est pour ça sourit il faut à
chaque fois essayer de rapprocher sa de
ce l'on peut faire vous savez qu'il ya
une règle qui s'appelle la glâne réalité
budgétaire
autrement dit on vous attribue une
subvention à une association l'année
prochaine vous pouvez depuis le donner
et c'est ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs
aux propos en 2014 ouais c'est notamment
pour une association de réalisation
c'est vrai que l'ancien maire donnait de
subventions peut-être que c'est un
argument suffisant louer ça il faut que
ça s'arrête là si nous sommes élus entre
m'ont dit 'nous prévoyons donc une
pluriannualité des subventions
attribuées
la loi nome ne me pose pas c'est évident
mais nous dirons publiquement pour que
les gens voient si on raconte des
blagues au comptant respecte comme on
dit et à passer ce mois les associations
qu'est-ce qui se passe à ce jeu les
bosses et bénévolement pour pouvoir
améliorer la situation citées en matière
financière éducation sexuelle ou autre
cette situation là doit être la règle
pour ce qui concerne la politique
municipale est là vous me parlez de 700
millions et demain jeudi à coup on
supprime apl est désormais on peut pas
travailler comme ça il faut une
visibilité et l'idée n'est pas que dans
ce domaine dont de l'emploi c'est dans
le domaine de l'organisation et des
priorités qu'on doit s'assigner vous
avez le problème de
des ravines et tribaux chose vous avez
des meurtres en parler c'est attention
après scellier donc à la résurgence donc
de d'épidémie de paraître l'épidémie
n'est toujours pas assurée sur trois ans
sur trois ans 12000 pec
ce n'est pas suffisant à mon sens il
faut il faut un travail beaucoup plus
conséquent mais apparemment on y faut
militer
je prends l'exemple vous avez vous avez
d'écran des transports moi je suis
persuadé que dans l'avenir
vous aurez des transports critique où on
aura un accompagnateur dans les bus au
delà du chauffeur qui n'aura plus à
conduire et n'ont plus encaissé l'argent
au pays sont point des gras mais ça
c'est un effort financier
que doit faire si le cal et comment
l'état peut aider
non on fait un tri par six voix là par
là et on croit éteindre le feu qui couve
sous la boue et l'eau douce a bruissé
par le maïdo il roulait transport parce
que vous avez une responsabilité dans ce
drame et pour finir sur les idées de
macron il a démarré sa vitre se
soumettent chose la réunion dans lequel
il annonçait leur faveur des
investisseurs étrangers
et puis il a développé cette idée de
l'espace indo pacifique
est-ce que ça a du sens d'abord de dire
vous avez sur la tranchée
est-ce que c'est ça qui me manque de
est-ce que cet espace indo pacifique
est-ce qu'il a un sens pour la réunion
politique militaire les analystes
soulignent que c'est une menace qui a
été développé pour contrer donc
notamment la chine donc donc je veux
dire jouer dans ce jeu géostratégique
nous nous sommes finalement la deux le
pion qu'on dit moi je pense qu'on a été
parmi les premiers à envisager que le
syndicat soit une zone de paix on est
loin du compte aujourd'hui il ya d'une
part chine à djibouti wathelet
il ya une stratégie donc de grandes
puissances faut aussi d'avoir des prix
dans la zone
je pense moi qu'on doit avoir un rôle à
jouer pour pouvoir être là dans un
élément de plus grande neutralité et à
ce titre je ne pense pas qu'on a société
notre avis faut que soit consacré une
telle stratégie
c'est ça le problème vous avez des ddd
self-made-man vd des jeunes chênes
entreprises ici qui se sont engagés en
afrique parce que tu bouges et à débit
sur une très forte croissance d'afrique
il voulait des réunions vous avez des
réunionnais qui sont au mozambique
est-ce qu'on va demander leur avis 0
mois de compétition je sais que personne
je tout de raconter pour réfléchir
jmahri sim par exemple 0 on peut plus et
c'est dans le même cadre que ce que je
vous dis et à leur exaspération des
jaunes 9 noeuds noeuds n'agissait pas
sans nous ne disait pas sans nous pour
nous est la même chose
comment voulez vous envisagez quoi un
rôle stratégique et puis j'ai investi
soit celui ci c'est faux vous n'êtes pas
concernés c'est un problème
oui vous avez sensibilités au sein du
conseil départemental popularisation des
transports en commun et sur ce qui se
passe dans ce domaine on a le sentiment
que les projets sont pile avec pas
forcément beaucoup de cohérence
[Musique]
évidemment on revient l'idée d'un
tram-train s'appelle own rails
aujourd'hui porté par la région mais qui
avance doucement et n est pas munua y
avait un monorail approché mon oreille
entre 50 et 100 de dia le projet tao
porté par la cinor oui dans la commune d
indiquer quand je vous ouvriez savent où
je je faire de la pub pour mon blog mais
j'avais un boulot j'ai dit d'arrêter
quand je regarde je vois beaucoup de
choses qui sont encore d'actualité il
avait dit votre look certes en 2015 soit
un téléphone qui sont encore d'actualité
notamment chez transforce si des gens
critiquer parce qu'on a supprimé des
arrêts sur des axes ou salade de revel
relevé pas notre compétence de la
compétence des agglomérations tc eau
sanitaire car succédera bon donc on en a
on a décidé donc de donner une priorité
qui est donne une vitesse qu'on a ça
nous apprend temps à critiquer là dessus
le maire de mer du port actuel avait dit
qu'il engagerait une action contre
département tout ça c'est des paroles
paroles paroles comme dit la chanson
d'un dos et david à et donc moi ce que
je sais c'est côté et nous dans notre
droit mais que ça posait un problème
pourquoi parce que contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser c'est des
personnes dont le match qu il y aurait
une augmentation de la fréquentation est
contre ce que pouvait penser le groupe
on a récupéré donc de l'argent
dm regarder avec 16,2 pour cent
d'augmentation fréquentation près d'un
million d'euros sa lancée du bus à ste
très mini aujourd'hui vide avons mis
sous toit
difficile donc je viens plus est en
augmentation et j'avais dit nous allons
vers l'impasse en se déplaçant parce que
cette augmentation m'ont donné ça n'aura
plus de sens parce qu'il y aura un temps
d'1 30 rôle on y voit des personnes qui
laissent pointer aux heures de pointe
et si on ne monte pas sur la fréquence
et cette augmentation fait qu'enfin d'un
nouveau problème c'est que ça sera une
saturation nouvelles caméras et qu'il
nous faudra passer par un autre une
infrastructure de transport tant mieux
oui les cars jaunes sont victimes de
leur succès et maintenant il ya des gens
qui sont agacés par ce que il ya place à
la saison de pointe ils sont pris dans
les embouteillages
ah s'il n'y a pas de voie réservée donc
si on n'a pas un plan résolument
volontariste qui ne concerne pas que les
parents et qu'elles concernent plus qui
concerne plus le départ donc je sais la
résidence mais tous les efforts qu
efficace lkj qui existaient sofa mixte
des transports qui existe le centro
alléluia oui on lui dit qu'est ce qui
fait justement parce que j'avais dit
quand je vous parle à combattre
transports comment voulez-vous moi j'ai
acheté marie mas saint guiral
j'ai pris le bus tous sont les parents
qui est tranquille et pas de risque
aujourd'hui vous avez des parents qui
souhaitent plus laisser d'un enfant de
12 ans wac prend le bus passe il n'ya
pas d'accompagnateur a par exemple à ça
coûte trop cher anaconda continueront
pour marché coûte cher et dont vous avez
des problèmes de dégradations et
incivilités cetera
donc on marche la tête et c'est vrai que
tant qu'on n'aura pas des voies
réservées pour améliorer donc le confort
de trajet des années
l'usager ça passera pas et c'est là
qu'interviennent les projets monorail
d'abord après enterré ensuite sera en
compétition avec le tao donc jouer là il
ya un manque de cohérence qui doit
assurer cette cohérence qui doit porter
cette couleur noire qui chargent
syndicaliste où il ya la région qui
quand même le maître de ce plan
réunionnais mais forcément concertation
avec les agglomérations et sa chance et
sinon on ira t on est là par exemple le
médecin dj lui le projet de chum c'est
que sinon assez lent mais hélas ça
repose un peu le problème c'est que
lorsqu'il y avait le tram train et les
héros apportées par les allocations
alors même que en principe dans le
projet de libérer pour l'aménagement et
l'urbanisme à la montagne 0 euros de
plus values immobilières pour la région
oh la la cinor franche ans la région a
de l'argent mais pourquoi il n'ya pas le
prolongement vers l'est
non c'est et puis après don c'est
d'envisager que ça ne s'arrêtent pas
entre l'est non je faisais pas d'énormes
problèmes du situation peut que vous
alliez dans le sud et là je parle pas de
la ville de saint-pierre à travers
hausse
vous avez envie des cabris donné tous
les problèmes figuration donc quand bon
ça veut dire que c'est plutôt la région
que tout ça se décide aujourd'hui je
pense que ce n'est pas qu'à région en
concertation mais une partie du pouvoir
est ce que c'est une excuse moi tu as
forcément
maintenant comme je voulais dit à
exactement dans le droit fil de ce que
j'ai dit à votre corps judiciaire si
demain il y à des combinaisons envisagé
pour la régie régionale sur quelle base
donc avant de créer un parti aussi grâce
auquel barre en son temps pouvoir le
voir mais concrètement qu'est ce qu'on
fait parce que je suis n'est plus la
même que ça d'avant où nous avions été
c'est pas à cause c'est parce que je
dirais paul vergès a exigé on a fini ce
cas-ci financière des finances de la
région et le rapport que first ceux qui
travaillent le ministre cite avec les
régions les départements des grandes
politiques d'aidé il faudra serrer si
vous voulez avoir des grandes
institutions en plus des lycéens conçu à
nouveau aujourd'hui pas demande un futur
sofa ou 2,8 waterman pas dit c'est un
lisez des dépenses supplémentaires via
des dépenses pour les ordinateurs mais
tout ça donc ça veut dire que la
situation financière la région est
beaucoup plus délicate donc demain on
rasera gratis et donc faut savoir
comment on fait prudemment ses idées à
l'équipe grâce à des projets les idées
puisque des personnes malades ou dans
quel état se trouve à gauche aujourd'hui
et ce qu'elle peut subir la gauche
réunionnaise
moi je sais qu'en tout cas il ya des
personnes à gauche qui ont très bien
favoriser les riches en deux présidents
de droite à je parle pas que de certains
vont comprendre 2015 mai 2006 donc moi
générique guaka 2010 sont que nos
auditeurs l'appui de sarkozy s'est dit
d'accord entre le bon si vous voulez
donc pour moi avant toute chose c'est
quel projet et vous avez a joint un fait
qui à prendre en compte sont ainsi
profit chaussée le fait micro régionales
vous avez un rééquilibre les gens de
tétouan être envisagée
je parle a donc de 2,2 est mennucci
ouest et donc dans ce cadre pour un con
qu'on discute sur la base de deux dash
en concrète et non pas vous êtes de
gauche on veut battre mâcon dont on
finit je suis tout ça c'est juger moi
c'est ça me dépasse je ne dirais pas
c'est pareil c'est vachement subalterne
je dis ça me dépasse pour moi
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on fait et
vous avez des gens que l'on dit de droit
toi qui peuvent envisager
des projets concrets et qui sont là les
gens qu'ils ont trahi au mont pour
l'instant j'en vois plus mes gènes
on peut discuter mais après la
discussion il faut le coc la
concrétisation d'un projet parce que
malgré tout pour ces municipales il ya
par endroits des passants qui sont en
place
pcr la france insoumise plr ps ça sera
pas d'être multi voilà c'est ça j'ai vu
cette géométrie sait jamais très
variable suivant les rues sur les
communes
vous êtes un parti ou une personnalité à
laquelle vous vous sentez en face moi je
n'y a aucun parti pour l'instant c'est
peu mais c'était jean hugues ratenon
c'est pas la france a soumise mais en ce
qui concerne le soutien à son parcours
son engagement quand j'ai soutenu je
marche
gg souviens c'était pas la france a
soumises c'était younous omarjee pour le
travail fait pour la réunion mais je
pense qu'il faut arriver à ça sinon on
arrive à des combinaisons
incompréhensible et je pense que sur le
plan des élections présidentielles
demain on sait bien inspirés comme on
s'y de m couvé par l'ego de mettre les
egos de côté parce que la situation est
émouvant 19,8 je crois c'était ou 18 9
j'ai envie que l'argent en 2017 je crois
que ça a un peu évolué oui et non c'est
les verts par bon ton monte mais ça va
ça vient la politique ou l'a13 vous
restez à bhl politique tout souligner le
très bon score quatre communes y compris
au port qu'est ce que ça vous dit qu'est
ce que c'est sans qu'il vous inquiète
tout ce que fait récemment lorsque en me
nommant 2002 il ya eu donc au port la
consigne au 2ème tour il faut vous déjà
pour faire barrage à jeun jamais imaginé
fait 92% bon mais il fait aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus le cas à signé exaspération
des gens je pense que on quand je vous
disais tout à l'heure que des fois on
dit bah c'est pas notre état après qu'on
peut pas sa faute de l'europe
faut arrêter avec ce monsieur les gens
en ont ras-le-bol et c'est à l'opr quel
il faut monter son peut faire nous et
après quand on peut plus par son arrivée
au boulou
ils ont demandé aussi soit les parements
un région à l'état loi mais ne
déroberons pas nos responsabilités et
les gens quand ils se disent ils sont
tous pareils c'est le rejet on va le
montrer et c soit mais ce n'est pas que
là dessus
j'avais il ya des types faut pas croire
qu'il ya pas un problème de dos 2-2 de
malaise à une immigration et donc on
sait bien ce pire il très attention et
donc non pas de visée du doigt de
montrer du doigt telle communauté
c'est au contraire d'envisager une
intégration sur la question
vraiment un problème posé de migration
on arrive à son admiration mais
abandonnée en fait très bien mais je
voulais que joe king jouet et vous avez
un problème aussi donc de flux
importants mariottat réunion il faut
intégrer
il ne faut surtout pas se dire on va les
traiter en communautaires ont ça a été
beaucoup
le bruit est menée par le passé et
encore aujourd'hui on isole ces
communautés c'est un danger que
d'envisager demain notre avenir du
vivant comme ça qu'on a travaillé à
faire ce sens qui sont plus prompts à
votre situation
votre en pauvres nous et sa retraite
pendant je suis toujours donc à
disposition du cnfpt
c'est le centre national de franche suis
au grade d'administrateur
je sais que je paye un peu aussi on
engagement politique qui fait qu au plan
administratif il y a des réticences des
fois ce que je puisse donc être recrutés
internat grade
donc je vais vous travaillez pas non je
ne rêve pas de charge
je suis pas à la rue finances avant mais
je vais en plein jour annonce je serai
un retraité de mars 2020 mais bien que
plusieurs années vous avez eu ce sera
sans travailler j'ai eu 50 % du salaire
puisqu'il ya une remise en cause par
jean pas un
l'arrêt du conseil d'état d'autre part
par là une loi votée pas hollande de
direction de 5% chaque année de salaire
donc pas majoration de salaire
programmant son prêt français entend
fonctionnaires 5% et en ou 2020 si
j'avais continué ses 10% de son énergie
à 10%
mais ça c'est grâce à un vide en marche
pour aligner le public sur le privé mais
pas four est très bon niveau
c'est pour régresser tout le monde vous
connaissez c'est tout le débat sur
l'assurance chômage
et comment vont être pénalisés encore
plus ou mois moi je ne pleure pas sur
mon sort mais je sais que c'est quand
même et il
ce qui est encore passé
contrat fonction publique est contre et
privés justin et rapide sur le mode de
campagne parce que voilà ma vie à faire
une campagne 2.0 parce que ça coûte cher
parce que c'est pas seulement sa couche
je crois pas c'est surtout que c'est du
spa qui gaspillent et qu'on retrouve des
fois la rue des eaux et donc pour éviter
ça c'est une campagne numérique sur la
plateforme youtube cosy tout document on
se cache pas pour autant de votes mais
un travail de porte-à-porte
un avis de réunion qu'a fait un travail
de contact mais le moins de papier aussi
son retour sur le terrain ça vous
sembler oui je vous aime vous voyez bien
que j'aime ça merci bien d'un geste est
notre invité dans le lundi politique
passé une excellente a réuni sur la
première
[Musique]
12h15 13 heures que le club de la presse
sur la première on va parler d'eux
élections européennes qui font de la
corse rien sauf une chose qu'il faut pas
croire qu'il y avait une vraie tentative
de conjonction entre didier robert et
mais qu'on soit pour ou contre moi je
vous dis je suis ni pour ni contre le
club de la presse tous les mardis de
12h15 à 13h avec gueye le dantec sur la
première vous plus beaux souvenirs avec
la première